MALE SPEAKER: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today I
want to finish up
thinking about circuits.
And the major topic for
today is just one --
thinking about abstractions that
we can use for thinking
about circuits.
The attractions are things that
capitalize on linearity.
And they include things like
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and
superposition.
OK so what I want to
do is finish up
thinking about circuits.
And just to get you thinking
about circuits, let's think
about where we are.
Last time we saw that one of the
issues in thinking about
circuit design, is the fact that
every part, in principle,
interacts with every
other part.
Which makes the design process
harder than the design process
was for things like linear
systems, where we thought
about boxes having inputs
and outputs.
In linear systems, when we
thought about boxes having
inputs and outputs, the output
didn't necessarily have any
affect on the input,
unless there was an
explicit path feedback.
In circuits, there's
feedback always.
There's no way to avoid it.
And in fact, that coupling can
make thinking about the
circuits very difficult.
And we introduce that idea by
just thinking about, even if
you wanted to close a switch,
you know a circuit, that's
logically the same as
adding a new part.
And when you do that, that's
going to change the currents
and voltages everywhere.
So that's kind of a big thing--
that's kind of the
thing that's different about
circuits from what we've been
thinking about before.
Because that complicates design,
we'd like some way of
dealing with it.
And the way we introduced, and
the way that you used in the
lab, so far, has been
to use a buffer.
We can use an op-amp
to make a buffer.
And a buffer has this nice
isolation property.
In this particular circuit, it
has the property that it
copies this voltage to the
output, regardless of what's
at the output.
That means we could put a switch
here, we could change
the light bulb, we could do
anything we wanted to, and we
would still know, because of the
properties of the op-amp,
we would still know that this
voltage is going to be 8
Volts, regardless of
what we put there.
So that's very nice, that gives
us a modularity, that
gives us a way to
design things.
It let's us design the left--
make a circuit that generates
8 Volts without knowing
precisely what's going
to be the ultimate
circuit that that drives.
So that's nice, it allows
us to do modularity.
And in many instances, that's
a very good solution.
In fact in the solution-- in
the problems that you are
working on in lab, where you're
trying to drive a motor--
that's an excellent solution.
It's not always an excellent
solution.
In some sense, it's
very expensive.
An op-amp is a complicated
part.
If you were to look inside an
op-amp, there's some two dozen
transistors in most op-amps.
So it's not an inexpensive
part, especially when you
think about this kind of a
circuit that only has three
parts to the left.
The op-amp is actually a more
complex device than
anything else up.
So op-amps are wonderful,
op-amps allow us to make
buffers, buffers are wonderful,
but they're not
always the best solution for
thinking about modularity.
And, in fact, there's
other ways.
And so that's what we want to
think about today is -- other
ways for achieving modularity
in circuit design.
And the key to thinking about
this, is to think about, well,
what's the worst thing
that could happen?
If I changed this part
arbitrarily, just how bad can
things get?
So I'll let you answer that.
Think about that circuit, and
assume that this is a 90 Volt
power supply, 3 Ohm, 6 Ohm,
but this can change--
R0 can change.
I've tabulated some values of R0
and putative, corresponding
values for V0 and I0.
Are my putative answers right?
So take a minute, talk to
your neighbor, figure
out how many of these--
let's see-- ten blue numbers
are right or wrong.
It's very quiet, you are allowed
to talk to people.
So how many of the numbers
are wrong?
So raise your hand, indicate
by number fingers how many
mistakes are in the table.
More votes, more votes--
come on, come on.
if you had talked more, you
could blame it on your
neighbor more easily,
so talk quickly.
OK.
So does everybody agree
with their neighbor?
OK, i don't see a single
right answer.
So take 30 more seconds and
think about it again.
I don't see any right answers.
So assume your answer's wrong.
[CHUCKLES]
Color blind--
OK, so how many of
the voltages and
currents are incorrect?
OK, how about a re-vote?
So how many of the
blue numbers--
the currents and voltages,
how many of V0 and I0 --
how many of those
are incorrect?
OK, not very many votes--
I'd say about 80%
correct, now.
That's definitely
an improvement.
What would have to be true?
If I wanted to prove that some
of these numbers were wrong,
what could I do?
Give me a condition that would
have to be true if the numbers
were correct.
AUDIENCE: V0 has to equal I0?
PROFESSOR: V0 has to equal I0.
We know that this resistor
better be--
better obey Ohm's Law.
That's what we mean
by that symbol.
So it had better be the
case that V0 is I0R0.
So you you'd want this
number to be the
product of that and that.
So 0 is the product of 0 and
30, that looks good.
30 is 2 times 15, 36 is 3 times
12, 48 is 6 times 8.
60 is--
well that's a little marginal.
how about if I rearrange it
a little bit, and say
what if R is V/I?
If I is 0, that would make the
resistor infinity, so there's
a way of thinking about that
last line as correct.
That's a little funny.
Maybe the forward way of
thinking about it is, well
what if I made the resistor
infinite?
if I made the resistor infinite,
what would be I?
0.
And what would be V?
What would be the voltage
difference if
this were right, then?
The voltage divider--
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
PROFESSOR: So if there's no
current here, then you can use
the voltage relationship--
the voltage-divider
relationship here.
6 over (3 plus 6) times 90 --
which is 60.
So if you use straightforward
reasoning saying, what if the
resistor was infinitely large?
What would happen?
Then you would conclude that
the bottom line is OK.
If you choose--
if you show that R equals
V over I, are you done?
What else has to be true
in order for the
numbers to be true?
It's not very hard.
AUDIENCE: The voltages drop out
of the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
The resistor has to be
the same as the--
PROFESSOR: So the voltages--
that's an instance--
what you just said-- is
an instance of KVL.
Basically, the voltage around
all of the loops better be 0.
The sum of the voltages around
all of the loops better be 0,
and the sum of the currents in
all of those closed surfaces
better be 0, right?
KVL better be satisfied
everywhere, and KCL better be
satisfied everywhere.
So, in particular, we can
ask about this node.
We could say, do the currents
flowing into
that node sum to 0?
So if you take a line here--
let's take this line--
if V0 happened to be--
V0 happens to be the voltage
here, right?
So if V0 were 36, then that puts
some voltage on this leg.
36 would what, 54?
So then you'd have to say--
you'd have to compute, then, the
current through here and
the current through there,
and see if those
currents sum to 0.
And, in fact, if you do those
calculations, you if you can
convince yourself of
those are all true.
So the answer was 0.
All of those answers
were true.
The point of doing the exercise
was to just remind
you about how you solve
circuits, but also to let us
look at patterns.
The interesting thing in this
problem is the pattern the
results between the
V's and the I's.
So if I were to make a plot, in
fact, those V's and I's all
fall on a straight line.
Well that's pretty
interesting.
So if I plot just this
V versus this I--
so V equals 0, 30, 36,
0, 30, 36, 48, 60 --
and the corresponding
I's, 30,15,12,6,0 --
30,15,12,6,0.
Those points all fall
on a straight line.
That suggests that there's
some pattern here.
And if there's a pattern, then
there might be a way to
exploit it.
So that's what I'm trying
to develop--
is a way to exploit the pattern
that results when
parts of circuits interact.
The interesting thing
that we--
so not only is it true that
there's a simple pattern, but
it turns out that the pattern
is completely independent of
the thing that I put
on the right.
The pattern is a property of
the circuit to the left.
One way to convince yourself
of that is to substitute--
take that resistor out, and put
in a voltage source, and
redo the problem.
This time, instead of assuming
that there's an Ohm's Law-type
resistor here, assume there's
a constant voltage, and that
constant voltage is adjusted
to 0,30,36,48,60.
If you re-solve that
problem, you get
exactly these same currents.
The answer continues to fall
on exactly the same line.
So that's a very interesting
pattern.
The idea is that when the
circuit on the left interacts
with the circuit on the right,
regardless of what the circuit
on the right is, you get a
simple relationship between
the voltage and current
that comes out of the
circuit on the left.
So that motivates the idea that
we can think about the
left-hand circuit as some
kind of a generic part.
We call that generic
part a one-port.
Think about this circuit on the
left-- the thing that's in
the red box--
it's got at its terminals--
the terminals are the things
that poke through the red box.
First off it has two terminals,
two terminals is
just like all of our
other parts.
And it's like a resistor, it's
like a voltage source, it's
like a current source, it's
a two terminal device.
And just like a voltage source
or a resistor or a current
source, there's some voltage
across those terminals, and
there's some current that flows
in those terminals.
So there's some current
that goes in the plus.
And that same current
comes out the minus.
That'll be true for this
circuit, just the same as it's
true for a resistor or voltage
source or anything else, the
only difference is, the thing
that's inside the box--
the thing that's inside
the one-port--
is more complicated than it was
for a simple resistor or
voltage source or
current source.
So what we can think about, is
this whole red box just looks
like a super part.
So the interesting thing that
happens is, this red box
behaves like a one-port,
like a super part.
And just like a resistor has a
relationship between V and I,
V equals IR, Or a voltage source
has some kind of a
constraint, V equals V0.
Or a current source
has some kind of a
constraint, I equals I0.
This funny part has a
relationship between V and I
that's given by that curve.
In some sense, it's not
very different.
So we think that--
so what we want to do now is
figure out the rules that
govern the currents
and voltages that
flow through one-ports.
And in particular, how special
was this straight line thing?
I mean if they were always a
straight line, that would be
really easy, right?
So the question--
so the next question I'd like to
ask is, just how often are
we expecting to see straight
lines there?
I already said, the primitive
elements that we think about--
Ohm's Law, resistors, voltage
sources, current sources--
they have straight line
constraints between the
voltages and currents that
they can generate.
So think about what I'm doing.
I'm trying to think about a rule
that's going to let me
describe the currents and
voltages into that red box
from the previous slide, much
like I would describe the
voltages and currents in an
Ohm's Law a resistor.
I can tell you the
voltage-current relationship,
V equals IR for an Ohm's
resistor, independent of what
it's connected to.
That's the reasoning that
I'm using here.
I'm going to try to figure out,
independent of what it is
connected to, what will be the
voltage-current relationship
for the red box?
So the question is, when are we
expecting straight lines,
and when are we not expecting
straight lines?
So here's a simple circuit.
Here's a super part made out
of one linear resistor, one
Ohm's Law resistor, and
one voltage source.
What's the current-voltage
relationship for that part?
What if I put a red box around
the whole thing, and asked you
to draw the I-V curve, the
current voltage curve?
Which would it look
like, A,B,C,D --
which should have been
(1), (2), (3), (4) --
so you can raise fingers,
or none of the above?
So take 30 seconds.
Figure out what would be the
I-V curve for this part.
So if you map A to D
into (1) to (4) --
which of those plots describes
the current-voltage
relationship for that circuit?
Map A to D to (1) to (4).
OK, you're quiet, and the
success rate is smaller than
usual, about 50% correct.
Take 30 seconds, reconsider your
answer, try to get this
up to 85% or so.
[CHATTER]
So which is the best plot?
Which plot best characterizes
the circuit on the top?
OK, that's much better.
That's about 75%.
Certainly not 100%,
but better.
OK so how do you think
about this?
One way to think about
it is special cases.
Can you think about any
special cases that are
particularly easy to check?
0 --
OK, what equals 0?
AUDIENCE: V or I --
PROFESSOR: V or I --
yes.
So what if you were to make --
if you were to make
I equal to 0?
First off, if you made
I equal to 0, what's
special in the plots?
If I equals 0, then you
round up x-axis.
Sorry, if you make I
0, what will V be?
If you made I be 0,
how big will be V?
5 Volts, right?
If you make I be 0,
then there's no
voltage across the resistor.
So the total voltage here will
be the same as the voltage
across the voltage source,
V equals 5.
So the intersection on the
x-axis should be at the point
V equals 5.
Makes sense?
Now if you said V equals
0, how big would I be?
If you set V equal to 0 -- how
do you set V equal to 0?
AUDIENCE: Negative 2.5.
PROFESSOR: Negative 2.5, so
what is negative 2.5?
AUDIENCE: The value of I.
PROFESSOR: So do you need--
how do we set V equal to 0?
What's the circuit way of
saying, set V equal to 0?
You set V equals 0
in a circuit by--
AUDIENCE: Grounding.
PROFESSOR: --grounding,
by setting it--
by putting in a wire.
So you run a wire from
here to here.
Voltage across a wire
is always 0, right?
So you set something to 0 by
putting a wire across it.
We call that a short circuit.
OK, there's a short path
for the voltage travel.
So you put a short circuit here,
and then I becomes V
over R, and the only trick
is that it's up, right?
Current likes to flow down the
electrochemical gradient.
So it likes to go down the
electrical gradient.
So the current is going to
go up, but the reference
direction for this I is down,
so I is minus 2.5.
So the intersection on this
axis is minus 2.5.
So we know that it has to go
through a negative on the
bottom, and it has to go through
a positive V on the
x-axis, and the only curve
that does that is (A).
And if we wanted to be a little
bit more fancy, we
could figure out the
general rule.
We could just write an
expression for Vr.
Well by KVL, Vr is always
the difference
between V and 5 Volts.
And we could write an expression
for the current
through the resistor.
That's just V over R. Vr
is V minus 5, R is 2.
So I get some expression which
is, lo and behold, linear in
V. So just like that more
complicated circuit that I'd
looked at, I ended up with a
straight line relationship in
the current voltage--
the relationship between the
current and voltage falls on a
straight line.
So how special is that?
Well it actually happens
pretty robustly.
Think about what would happen
if I had two parts, the
generically--
so I'm thinking about these
being generic boxes, inside
could be anything.
There could be a current source,
a voltage source, a
linear resistor, or some
other one-port.
So if I had a generic box here,
and a generic box here,
and I connected them in
parallel, under the condition
that each of the generic boxes
had a straight line
current-voltage relationship,
it's easy to argue that the
resulting relationship between
current and voltage for the
parallel combination is
also a straight line.
All you need to do is realize
that if you hook two things in
parallel, the parallel voltage
is the same as V1 and V2.
So all the voltages
are the same.
And the currents add.
So Ip, the current end of the
parallel combination is the
sum of the two I's.
So if you think about the
relationship between V1 and
I1, and the relationship between
V2 and I2, you could
derive the relationship
between Ip
and Vp by just adding.
V1 equals v2 equals Vp, that's
what we saw here.
And the current at the
bottom is the sum of
the other two currents.
So, in particular, if this was
a straight line, and that was
a straight line, the sum of
two straight lines is a
straight line, right?
If you add two straight lines,
you get a new straight line.
So what this shows is that if
you started with parts that
were themselves straight lines,
parallel combinations
would generate a new part with
another straight line.
Same sort of thing happens if
the two parts we're in series.
In series we would
have Iseries --
it's the same as
I1 equals I2--
so that's the equivalent of the
y-axes, where previously
we had equivalents
of the x-axes.
And now if both of these boxes
had linear I-V curves, I would
now add horizontally rather
than adding vertically.
But I have the same result.
If the two, individual one-ports
had linear I-V
curves, and if I add
horizontally, I'll get a new
linear I-V curve.
And in fact, if you start--
if you put any combination of
parts that have linear I-V
curves together to form
a new circuit--
a new one-port, the I-V curve
for that new one-port will be
a linear function.
And the way to see that, is to
think about linear equations.
Remember when we solve a
circuit, we have to have one
law for every element, Like
Ohm's Law-- it's V equals IR,
or voltage source is V equals
V0 or something like that--
we need one law for
every element.
And then we have KVL and KCL.
Well all of the-- if we start
with the assumption that each
component has a straight line
relationship between voltage
and current, which is true for
linear resistors, voltage
sources, and current sources.
Those equations that describe
those parts are what we call
linear equations.
Linear equation is an equation
where the function of the
unknowns is a quote --
linear function.
It has the form--
some constant times an unknown,
plus some other
constant times some other
unknown, plus, in principle,
any number of those.
But it has to be a linear
function, so you're not
allowed to have things like
V-squared in there.
But if you think about things
like voltage sources and
current sources and Ohm's Law,
they don't have squares in
there, they're linear
equations.
And the idea then, when we're
solving for the I-V
relationship for this new
one-port thing, all we're
doing is we're solving a system
of linear equation.
Sort of in the abstract, the
idea is that we write down all
of the component equations
inside the box, we write down
all of the relevant KVL and
KCL, and then we solve.
So they're all going to have--
each one of those equations is
going to be linear, so it's
going to be something like, say,
a0x0 if x is my unknown.
'x' could be a current
or a voltage.
And then I might have sum of x1,
then I might have sum of
x2, and I might have a whole
bunch of things, and they all
add together to be some
constant, like that.
So that might represent
part one--
that might represent one of
the components in the box.
Then I would have another
component, which would be some
other linear equation.
Then I'd have a KCL equation,
well KCL is easy, because that
only has currents in it,
and the multipliers are
all 1 or minus 1.
Right, so that's
clearly linear.
And I have KVL equations.
Those are linear.
And the point is, that when you
solve linear equations,
you get a new linear equation.
So think about solving this by
the method of substitution.
I could figure out
what is x0 here.
If I use this equation
to figure out x0.
x0 would be a linear function
of all the other x's.
So then if I plug that linear
function into here, I replace
this linear equation with a new
linear equation with one
fewer unknown.
if I keep doing that, I just
keep replacing linear
equations with other
linear equations.
When I'm all done, I'm left with
a new linear equation.
That's why, if you start with
parts that linear I-V curves,
you'll end up with a straight
line I-V curve.
So that idea that the I-V
function is a straight line is
quite robust.
It will happen anytime you go
to circuit out of ideal
parts-- whereby ideal parts,
I mean Ohm's Law resistors,
voltage sources, and
current sources.
So that has a very interesting
circuit interpretation.
If I know that an arbitrary
circuit can be represented by
a straight line--
if the I-V curve can
be represented
by a straight line--
well that generates
an equivalent set.
There's obviously more than
one circuit that could
generate the same
straight line.
Here's a circuit that can
generate that straight line.
In fact, it will always be true
that I can generate a
circuit with one voltage source
and one Ohm's Law
resistor that will mimic the
behavior of any arbitrary
combination of resistors,
voltage
sources, and current sources.
All I need to do is think
about, you take the
complicated thing, figure out
its straight line plot, now
you read off some critical
numbers from this plot.
You say, OK, well what if
the current were 0?
Well if the current were
0, I'd be on this axis.
If the current were 0 in the
circuit, V would be V0.
So that means you look over
here, you figure out the
x-intercept, and the x-intercept
is the value of
the voltage source.
Similarly, if you figure out
the rate of growth of I --
so more generally, if you solve
for I, I will be the
difference between V and V0
divided by R, that's just
Ohm's law for the resistor.
And that then lets you figure
out the law for the slope.
The slope over here is going
to turn out to be one over
this resistor--
I should have had--
this should be R0,
these two should match.
So the slope of this line is
one over that resistor.
So in general, regardless of
how complicated the box is,
figure out the straight line and
I-V curves, read off the
x-axis, read off the slope, and
that lets you construct a
simple circuit that has
the same Vi curve.
We call that circuit the
Thevenin Equivalent.
What that means is, you can
think about a complicated
circuit, regardless of how many
parts, by a circuit it
just has two.
That's an abstraction that
lets us think more simply
about complicated circuits even
if there's no buffers.
This is true always.
OK, it's not true--
it's not it's not the case that
if I change the thing
that I put here--
if I change the thing I put
here, this relationship is
still true.
It's the equivalent of Ohm's Law
for complicated circuits.
Ohm's Law is what I get
if what's in the
box is a single resistor.
If what's in the box is
complicated, more generally
this is what I get, the
Thevenin Equivalent.
Of course there's lots
of circuits that
have this I-V curve.
So a different one is a current
source with a resistor.
That's called a Norton
Equivalent.
You do the same sort of thing.
What would happen if here,
if I set V to be 0?
Well how do I make V be 0?
I make V be 0 --
Did I write that on the slide?
no I didn't write
it on the slide.
I make V be 0 by putting
a short circuit here.
I connect a wire.
If I put a wire here, then
how big is the current I?
Well if I put a wire here, it's
easier for this current
to go through the wire
than it is to go
through that resistor.
So all of this current goes
through the wire.
All of this current is I0.
So if I put a short circuit
across V --
if I make V be 0,
how big is i?
Minus I0 right?
All the current I0
goes through, it
just goes to backwards.
So that's how I get
this point.
So if I wanted to replace some
complicated circuit with a
Norton Equivalent, I would take
the complicated system,
to figure out the I-V curve,
read off the intercept on this
axis, change the sign--
that's the most confusing
part, by the way.
This is the error that
you all make.
There's a minus sign in the
current relationship.
We like to draw-- it just makes
us feel good to have the
arrow go up.
And if you make the arrow
go up, it's in the wrong
direction to I. So when we did
the Thevenin equivalent, there
was no sign from it,
this was V0.
So the voltage on the voltage
source is equal to the
x-intercept.
But when we do the Norton, the
current in the current source
is minus the y-intercept.
Same idea, though.
OK?
So the idea is that Thevenin and
Norton equivalent circuits
are equivalent, in the
sense that they
generate the same voltage.
that the more complicated
circuit did.
So that means for thinking
about the circuit we can
ignore the complicated stuff,
and just know two numbers, V0
and R0, or I0 and R0.
So one more step, what this all
means is, that if you can
represent the current voltage
relationship for an arbitrary
circuit in terms of a straight
line, that means that when
we're trying to characterize
an arbitrary circuit, it
doesn't matter how complicated
it is.
It could have 100 parts in it.
Regardless of how complicated it
is, I only need to measure
two things in order to fully
characterize it.
If a circuit is made out of
linear resistors, voltage
sources, and current sources,
three special linear parts--
if a circuit is composed
entirely out of linear parts,
doesn't matter how many parts
are in it, there could 100,
there could be 1,000--
I only need to measure two
things to get a complete
description.
And that's because two points
determine a straight line.
I know, by having proved it by
using linear algebra, I know
by using linear algebra
that the solution
is a straight line.
I know from geometry
that two points
determine a straight line.
I only need to find
out two points.
So by convention, the easiest
two points is usually the
simplest cases.
Set the voltage to 0 and set
the current to be 0.
So that motivates the idea that
if I have an arbitrary
circuit, if I want to figure
out this reduced complexity
abstraction--
say I want to make a Thevenin
Equivalent--
what I would do is first to ask
the question, how big is
the open circuit voltage?
Open circuit means there's no
connection between the terminals.
That means the current is 0.
If the current is 0,
I'm on the x-axis.
So over here I'm on the x-axis,
so I'm thinking about
the red point.
Open circuit over here means
there's no connection here,
which means the current is 0,
and all I need to ask is--
regardless of how complicated
it is the circuit--
how big is the voltage that
I would measure here?
So in this circuit,
if I have a--
yeah, I confused myself
for a moment.
if this current is 0, then
this voltage drop is 0.
This voltage source prescribes
the voltage between these
nodes to be 1 Volt,
so V0 is 1 Volt.
So I just fell one point.
I set I to be 0, I found the
open circuit voltage.
Then I need to find one
other point, because I
only to find two.
So I'll find the short
circuit current.
Imagine that I put a wire
between the input and the
output, and I'll compute how
much current that circuit
generates in that wire.
Again the only confusing part
is that the reference
directions are backwards to
the way you might have
expected them to be.
If I put a short circuit here,
then the voltage between these
nodes is still 1 Volt.
That's what the voltage
source always says.
So the current that flows
through this wire, the short
circuit current, is just this V
over that R, except it's in
the negative direction.
And the way you can think about
that is that the slope
of this curve has
to be positive.
I need-- because of the
way Ohm's Law works--
increasing the voltage better
tends to increase the current,
because that's what Ohm's
Law resistors do.
So I need to have this slope be
positive if it's going to
be Ohm's Law.
So I characterize just those
two points, and then the
resistance is simply the
ratio of the two.
So the resistance is related
to the slope.
It's 1 over the slope,
you don't need
to worry about that.
The resistance is always V over
I, so you just take the
open circuit voltage and divide
by the short circuit
current, minus sign, and
you get that the
resistor must be 2 Ohms.
Is that all clear?
The idea is that we're trying
to build an abstraction that
lets us simplify the way we
think about circuits, without
introducing buffers.
So that means then that these
two circuits are equivalent to
that circuit, in the sense
that they all share
the same I-V curve.
If you substituted one server
for the other, you couldn't
tell from outside the red
box which was on the
inside of the red box.
OK so I'll do an example now.
Think about, what if I want
to find the equivalent--
the Thevenin equivalent
for this circuit.
I just do the things I
just told you to do.
First thing I think about
is, what's the
open circuit voltage?
So If I think about open
circuit, there's
no connection here.
That means this current is 0.
That means that the voltage
that develops
is the voltage divider.
So I get 7 and a 1/2 volts--
3 over (1 plus 3)
times 10, right.
So that gives me one point--
that tells me the voltage
source for the Thevenin
equivalent.
Then for the second point, I
want to think about the short
circuit current.
So I consider putting a wire
here, and then I compute the
amount of current that
flows in that wire.
And in this circuit, this wire
shorts out that resistor, so
all the current goes through
this wire, and none of the
current goes through
that resistor.
So that means that the total
current that flows is 10 Volts
divided by 1 Ohm, which
is 10 Amps.
And then I know that the
equivalent resistance is the
ratio of the open circuit
voltage to the short circuit
current, except I have to worry
about the minus sign.
And so I end up with the
equivalent resistance being
the 7.5 Volts, which is the open
circuit voltage, divided
by 10 Amps, so I get 7.5 Ohms.
And so the answer then, is that
here is the circuit I
started with, here's the
Thevenin equivalent circuit,
they're identical in the
sense that they have
the same I-V curve.
And you can just sort of see
why that has to be true.
If you think about, here's the
two circuits, and if you think
about the simple cases, if you
set I to be 0, the voltages
better be the same.
Well over here it's 7.5 by the
voltage divider, over here
it's 7.5 by the fact that
there's no current going
through that resistor.
And the short circuit current
better be the same.
So over here, if you short this
out, you're going to get
10 Amps, over here if you short
it out, you're going to
get 10 Amps.
So you can always go
back and forth.
The point is, that you can
substitute the simpler circuit
for the more complex circuit,
because they have
the same I-V curve.
OK, just to make sure that
you're following me, here's a
question that has to do with
taking the same circuit, but
considering the Thevenin
equivalent--
Thevenin or Norton
at three different ports.
Here I'm thinking about what
would happen if I looked in
terminal A, what if I looked
in terminal B, or looked in
terminal C?
Figure out the Thevenin and
Norton parameters, and see if
there's an error in the table.
So how many errors
are in the table?
About 50% correct again.
So which entry don't you like.
AUDIENCE: 2D?
PROFESSOR: That's exactly
right, so 2D is wrong.
How do I figure out 1A?
How do I figure out V0
for the a circuit?
So the definition of V0 is
the open circuit voltage.
So I need to figure out, for the
a circuit, how big would
be the voltage across A if there
was no current flowing
in the leg of A. Everybody
clear on that?
So the thing that I would do
is, I would think about,
there's no connection here.
What's the voltage here?
So how would I calculate that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You would use the
current-divider relationship
to figure out that current
flowing through that is going
to be 4 Amps.
PROFESSOR: Precisely, so first
I need to take-- here are the
current sources, so I have two
resistor lengths, so that's a
perfect set up for the
current divider.
So the amount of current that
goes in this leg compared to
that leg is the ratio of this
resistance to the sum of
resistances, right?
And if you work that out, you're
going to get 4 Amps
coming through here.
So then after you know the
current through this leg, it's
an easy matter to take the
current and turn it into a
voltage, so the voltage at the
a port is 4 Amps times 5 Ohms
is 20 Volts.
Is that clear?
And similarly, but with a
different answer, the voltage
at the B terminal is the same 4
Amps, but now times 10 Ohms.
So that's how we got 40.
And at C, it's the same 4 Amps,
but now it's times the
sum, 4 times 15 is 60.
Everybody's happy about that?
So the point is that when you
generate an equivalent
circuit, it depends upon which
set of terminals you're using.
You can't just take a circuit
and say, give me the Thevenin
Equivalent.
You have to say, give
me the Thevenin
equivalent looking somewhere.
So I could look in the A port,
the B port, or the C port, and
I get different V0's.
How would I compute the I0?
Short circuit current--
so what I would do is I
would short this out.
When I do that, all the current
flows in this leg and
one of the current
flows that leg.
So that means I have,
equivalently, 10 Ohms in
parallel with 10 Ohms.
Then by the current divider,
how much current
goes down one leg?
Half of it.
I get a different answer over
here, because now I short out
that node, which shorts out that
resistor, so now I get a
different ratio of resistors.
It's not the same as the first,
so I know that this
answer can't be 5.
And, in fact, if you work it
out, the answer is 20 over 3.
And finally, if you short here,
then you know that that
short circuit shorts out
both this series
combination and that one.
So all of the 10 Amps goes
through that, so
you get that 10 Amps.
Then how do you get R0, which
is the ratio of V0 over I0.
So if you take V0 over
I0, you get 4.
Here if you do right answer, you
get 6, and here if you do
that you get 6.
The point is, that the Thevenin
equivalent you get is different.
The Norton equivalent that you
get is different, depending on
which ports you're looking at.
OK there's two reasons for
thinking about this.
One--
so why am I thinking about all
of these equivalent circuits?
So I wanted to have an
abstraction that was useful
for thinking about how
parts interact.
I wanted a way of thinking about
what would happen if I
changed the load on the circuit
without having to
recalculate all the voltages
and currents
throughout the circuit.
And so this Thevenin and
Norton idea is a
way of doing that.
That's important from a
practical sense, because when
you buy a part--
when you buy an electronic part,
they tell you how it
works by telling you the
Thevenin equivalent or the
Norton equivalent, or whatever
is the easy way
to think about it.
So there's a practical
reason--
when you buy an op-amp, they
tell you how good the op-amp
is by telling you how big is the
equivalent resistance at
the output.
So it has a practical value,
because it lets you-- it's the
way you specify an
electronic part.
You can't -- when the
manufacturer makes a part,
they can't know what you're
going to do with it.
So they tell you how it works by
telling you something about
the equivalent circuit.
There's also a different reason
for thinking about
this, and that is because it's
conceptually simplifying to
think about Thevenin and
Norton equivalents.
So here's an example that's
very much like the first
problem that I worked out.
What would be the effect
of closing this switch
on the current I?
We solved the problem very much
like this last time, and
one way you can solve it is you
figure out I in two cases,
when the switch is open and
when the switch is closed.
And you figure out whether went
up or down, and you know
the answer.
The point is, that if you think
about this in terms of
equivalent circuits, it's
completely trivial.
If I think about what
would happen--
I'm interested in what happens
at I, what I do is split the
circuit into two pieces, the
stuff to the left of I, and
the stuff to the right to
of I. I make a Thevenin
equivalent for both of them,
and then I jam together the
two Thevenin equivalents.
What I get, in detail,
is showed here.
So if I look left, I see
a 20 Volt source with
a 4, 4, and a 2.
That has a Thevenin equivalent
that is showed here, which is
independent of the state
of the switch.
So the same Thevenin occurs on
the two sides, switch open, or
switch closed.
If i make a Thevenin over here,
there's no sources.
So it's just going to
be a resistance.
So when the switch is open,
I have to 2 Ohms, when the
switch is closed,
I have 1 Ohm.
I don't even need to figure out
what are these part values
to see that, if I make this
resistance smaller, which
happens if I close the switch,
the current goes up.
I mean it's true that I showed
here that the Thevenin voltage
is 10 and the Thevenin
resistor is 4.
I don't even care.
Regardless of what the
Thevenin voltage was,
regardless of what the Thevenin
current is, it's
going to be the same when the
switch is open and closed.
And that's a powerful
statement.
I know it's the same, so when
I close this which, all I've
really done is I've made
that resistor smaller.
The net series resistance is
down, the current is up.
So I have two reasons for
thinking about Thevenin and
Norton equivalence.
One is practical value, the
other is conceptual
simplicity.
It lets you simplify way you
think about a circuit, and
it's a way of gaining intuition
without ever even
solving the equations.
Most circuit designers don't
solve certain equations.
They know what it's going to do
just by looking at it, and
this is the kind of reasoning
that they use.
OK, there's one more topic--
the idea of Thevenins and
Nortons really derived from
linear algebra.
The basic parts of most
interest are linear.
And when you put together a
system out of linear parts,
you get a linear system.
There's one more consequence of
linearity that is terribly
useful, and that's the idea
of super position.
If you have a system of
equations that is linear, and
if you have multiple sources,
things are very simple.
You can see that over here.
If I had multiple sources, the
system of equations that I get
wouldn't look quite like this.
These terms, the constant terms,
they're the ones that
come from the drives,
the voltage
sources, the current sources.
So if I had two drives, I would
get something else here.
I would get plus a at
N+1 for example--
source one, source two.
And I would get source
one, source two.
So the idea is that, if I have
a system that has multiple
sources, I know from the
structure of the linear
equations, there is just
more constant terms.
OK, well what's that mean?
That means you can just use
linear algebra to see that the
answer to this problem is the
sum of the answers to that
problem plus the answers
to that problem.
That's just linear algebra.
What that means in terms of
circuits is, I can figure out
the response to a circuit
by turning on the
sources one at a time.
That's called superposition.
And generally speaking, it's a
lot easier than solving the
circuit out the long way.
So here I've got two sources So
say I wanted to compute I,
in response to V0 and I0.
What I would do, is I would turn
off the I0 source, and
calculate the voltage
that results just
from the voltage source.
That's the same as setting
this to 0 and finding the
response to this.
So if I want to set I to 0, the
way you set I to be 0 is
open circuit.
If you open circuit something,
there's no current going to
flow through it.
So I replace the current source
with an open circuit,
and compute the i that would
be result when the current
source isn't there.
OK, well that's easy.
If their current source
we're not there, this
would be open circuit.
The current, i, would just be
the total voltage going
through R1 and R2.
So the answer, I1, the first
component of the current I,
would be V0, the result of the
voltage source divided by the
sum of R1 and R2.
Now that's not the
whole answer.
That would be the whole answer
if I0 weren't there.
So now I have to worry
about the other case.
What if only I0 were there?
Well now I have to
set V to be 0.
Well setting V to 0 is not
open circuiting it.
You can't just reach in, grab
the voltage source, and throw
it away, because that'll
make the current 0.
If I want the voltage to be 0,
I have to short circuit it.
So what I do then, is I leave
the current source alone, and
I replace the voltage source
with a short circuit,
guaranteeing that V is 0.
Then I ask, how big is I2, the
component of I that results
from the current source?
Well if I've short circuited
this, then I just get a
current divider.
This current has to do with
how readily the current
divides between R1 and R2.
The amount that goes through the
R1 side is in proportion
to R2 make R2 bigger, more
of it goes through R1.
Standard current divider,
except for the
slippery minus sign.
So if I only had the current
source, the current I2 would
have been current divider
operating I0 with the slippery
minus sign.
So that means, by superposition,
that the result
of having both sources on is
just the sum of those answers.
That's a very big
simplification.
If you've got multiple sources
in the circuit, you can think
about them all at once.
And if you really good at
writing linear equations and
solving them with pencils,
you'll get the right answer.
But there's an enormous
simplification if you just
turn off all but one, and
do them one at a time.
So here's a problem.
Here's a very simple
circuit, compute V
by using super position.
V is the voltage across
the resistor.
How big would V be if you used
the idea of super position?
So what's the answer?
50% correct, roughly speaking.
OK I want to use
superposition.
So how big would the voltage
v be, if all I had was the
voltage source?
One.
How big would the voltage
be if i only
had the current source?
Ah, got half of you.
That explains the 50% correct.
How big would the voltage
be, if I only
had the current source?
It's tempting to say (1).
I say tempting, because that's
the wrong answer.
[LAUGHTER]
What is wrong about
the answer (1)?
What does the voltage do
to the current source?
The voltage due to the current
source is the voltage that the
current source would have
generated if the voltage
source weren't there.
If the voltage source weren't
there, then--
half of you got it right,
so half of you
can shout the answer.
So if the voltage source weren't
there, the voltage
source would be 0.
If the voltage source were
0, then V would be 0.
So if the voltage due to the
voltage source is 1, the
voltage due to the current
source is 0.
The sum of the two is 1.
The answer is 1.
OK?
Make sense?
So, very closely related
problem.
What's the current I?
Solve that by superposition.
So how big is the current I
according to superposition?
Wonderful, so how big is the
current i generated by the
voltage source?
1.
How big is the I generated
by the current source?
Negative 1, the sum is 0.
All right, so those two problems
were trivial by
superposition.
They're not too hard by
non-superposition.
But the point is, that they're
trivial by super position.
So what we saw today--
the goal for today was to
generate some abstractions
that let you think about the way
parts interact with each
other, because that's a central
issue when you're
thinking about circuit design
And we built the idea of
Thevenins and Nortons
and super positions.
That was the basic idea.
And the sub-theme--
or maybe I should say the major
theme is really that.
It's the importance
of linear algebra.
So the take home message is
probably, take 18.06.
So this was all about the
application of 18.06 to the
solving of circuits.
See you later.